and hey
speaking of people who didn't do well in
polls
madison cawthorne has been back in the
news uh pretty much for about a week or
so now
because the guy just can't stop having
problems with his campaign finances
and i know that seems weird right
because the guy lost his primary
obviously he's not running for office
anymore he's he's a lame duck he's going
to be leaving at the end of the year
but
last week it was revealed
that madison cawthorne
is a month late
in filing his most recent campaign
finance disclosures
we also know
that in those disclosures that are still
waiting to be filed he's got thousands
of dollars that he's spent at
chick-fil-a
thousands of dollars that he's spent at
cigar shops
and uh what's some of the other 21 000
for lodging in florida three thousand
dollars at a place called papa's beer
and of course thousands uh hundreds of
thousands of dollars in consulting fees
that he's paid out to his consultants
who clearly did not do a very good job
for him
but he's a month late
hadn't filed it
and now according to a new report from
the daily beast
we know why
because as it turns out according to
this new report madison cawthorne is out
of money
the people working for his campaign said
it was basically dollar in dollar out
guy raised millions but he spent even
more than that
now you may not think that's a problem
right haha you ran out of money you're
not going to be reelected anyway so you
suck
it's a little bit murkier than that
though folks
you see there's a law believe it or not
we actually do still have a couple
campaign finance laws out there and one
of them
says that you can raise money for both
your primary race and the general
election race at the same time
good however
you cannot touch
that general election money
until you've won your primary and if you
don't win your primary
you have to pay all that money back to
the donors who gave it to you
the general election fund
doesn't matter what happens with your
primary money if you lose you lose
whatever but if you've raised money for
a general election and you lose your
primary all of the general election
money by law
has to go back to the people that gave
it to you and that makes sense right
that's actually protecting the donors
which explains why we have that law
because it protects the wealthy
corporations pouring money in
madison cawthorne as i said is out of
money
and he had a lot of money in his general
election fund
so
put two and two together and you realize
that madison cawthorne can't afford to
pay back all the money that he is
supposed to be paying back and that is
according to the people who worked with
his campaign that spoke to the daily
beast
so madison cawthorne's in a lot of
trouble here
he's going to have to come up possibly
with millions of dollars
to return to his donors
and that likely
again we can't say for certain but it is
likely
why he hasn't gone ahead and filed his
campaign finance disclosures because it
would show that he spent all the money
that he's legally not allowed to spend
so in addition to no longer being in
congress
he may no longer be a free man if he
continues to spend money so frivolously
that he's legally
not allowed to touch
if he does have any money left over
i'd say it's time to spend that on a
good lawyer